[Music]
for as long as I can remember I have
truly felt that my mom loves my sister
more than me and it hurts very badly
whenever I bring things up like this she
tells me that I'm crazy and she tells me
that I need to see a therapist because
I'm jealous of my sister and I can
promise you Dr John I'm not jealous of
my sister but I am jealous of my mom and
how she doesn't see how special and
beautiful I
[Music]
am hey what's up this this is John with
the Dr John deloney show we're so glad
that you're with us talking about your
marriage your mental health your
emotional health your relationship kids
whatever you got going on in your life
you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at
33291 and listen it makes such a huge
difference and Like It embarrasses me
with how big of a difference this makes
if for you just to run over to YouTube
and hit the Subscribe button it changes
everything about the algorithm changes
everything about putting this show into
other people's lives whether they even
asked for it or not and it begins to
give them help they didn't even know
they were looking for so if you will
like or subscribe or do all that stuff
um it makes such a huge difference for
the show but more importantly for your
neighbors people that you're not going
to talk to so um if you want to be on
the show like you said give us a buzz at
1844 693 3291 or go to John dooney.com
askas all right let's go to Iowa City
Iowa and talk to Riley what up
Riley Hi how are you doing today I'm all
right man how are
you um I'm I'm doing better than before
but but yeah so what's upang on what's
up so me and uh me and my wife um we
haven't been really been doing too good
these last few weeks I haven't been my
best um just found out um recently uh a
couple weeks ago she uh cheated on me
and uh I don't know I I just my heads
everywhere still and I just don't
know what to do I first was thinking
about rushing into a divorce um but once
I started getting on my emotions I
started thinking of maybe possibly
trying to work it out I I just don't
know because it's also hard because we
also have a one-year-old
and yeah how long you been married
manam uh sadly we've only been married
for about six months um but we were
together for about four
years
so you okay so you've been together for
four years and she cheated on you while
y'all were
dating uh no uh she cheated on me when
we were uh
married so you've only been married for
six months mhm so this is very recent
yes and you have a
one-year-old yes we have a one-year-old
okay so somewhere between the baby being
born and and then y'all getting
married um she was with somebody
else
um that's the thing I don't know if they
were really like it was like a long-term
thing or if it was just like a she told
me it was just like a one-time
thing
um so but you don't believe
that I don't know what to believe yeah I
don't know yeah I hate this for you
man yeah and it sucks cuz I'm only 22
and
I I understand that some parts um you
know I wasn't giving her you know more
love and affection that she wanted I
just I don't know I'm just I got a lot
on my mind lot on my plate so you're 22
you've been with the same woman for four
years you've been married for six months
you have a one-year-old baby and during
a recent discussion your wife told you
that hey within the last six months
within our time of being married um I
had a one night stand with
somebody and somebody not that's not you
and you're 2 you got a lot going on in
your
mind and um you don't really know which
way to
turn yeah yeah basically because I I
I've just been really set on wanting us
to get us you know financially stable
and living a life that you know a lot of
people could dream of
and um what are you doing for work right
now um just to you know bring money on
the table and provide I just do security
I make I make okay money there I I am
thinking about getting a new job though
or maybe getting a second job to bring
more money in but what's your wife do um
she works in assistant Care
Living okay do you all have child care
for your baby yeah okay um I think you
need to work three jobs
dude and your wife probably needs to
work one maybe two maybe if she needs to
be home with baby when as soon as she
can I get
that and this is separate than the
conversation here I'm going to circle
around and answer your original question
here but you sound like a 22y old guy
who the whole world just showed up in
your house and when I say the whole
world I mean reality and most 22y olds
especially in the US live in this
fantasy world it's not
real right like I want to follow my
passions and I want to have a unicorn
and a pony and and I don't want any
bills and I want to live in downtown
Manhattan and a 4,000 square like they
just don't live in reality and your
reality just hits you in the mouth you
have a baby you have a wife you're
dealing with infidelity you don't have
any
money I'm assuming you don't have a
degree or a career
trajectory um no I don't have no degree
or anything I the main thing I just want
to be is an author okay that's not for
today yeah I I've been a bestselling
author two times over three times over
number one twice and it didn't happen
till I was in my 40s and I've been
writing my whole life okay yeah so I
want you to you write every single day
of your life but you do that after the
baby's in bed and after your wife's
asleep yep right now we're working two
and three day two and three jobs because
you've got to get out of survival mode
because right now your head is so
clouded you don't even know up from down
left to right um and that makes the the
when your body's in fight or flight when
you're just trying to survive you don't
make good rational thinking rational um
uh you don't do things rationally
because your brain doesn't want you
thinking rationally it wants you to not
die it wants you to survive okay and so
the way we're going to get out of this
is by slowly getting your feet into
concrete standing on some kind of firm
foundation here one of that what those
steps is going to be Financial okay the
other thing is going to be you standing
up feeling a little bit more like um a
dad like a husband right and you don't
feel like that right now you still feel
like a little boy Fair yeah yeah you
feel like a little boy you're not you're
22 years old you can
vote I don't know if the options are
great but you can vote right and you're
G to be able to you have a kid you have
a wife you got stuff to do right so
we're going to get a couple of jobs and
we're going to do that today there's too
much work out there right now
okay that's number one number two do you
have a man in your life that you can sit
down and talk to uh yeah
who my my father is that a good person
to talk to oh he he's a great person to
talk to does he tell you the truth or
does he tell you what you want to hear
or does he try to make himself feel
better at your expense nope he's full on
blunt okay so what did he say when you
told him that you found out your wife
cheated on you uh he said that I should
give it just a couple weeks my head
clear well that's a good man then good
for him CU you you've you're like most
of us you have had this story in your
head like if anybody ever cheats on me
bro I'm out of here right you've said
that to yourself over and over right
yeah and then the idea of seeing your
daughter two days a week
maybe about rip your guts out doesn't
it uh yeah it it
definitely yeah and the thought of just
throwing away four years of be in a
relationship with somebody is pretty
brutal too right you love this woman oh
yeah no I I I love her okay here's the
thing that I don't know if yall have
done yet okay and I'm going to hook you
up with a couple of things to to help
you along the way
um y'all if you choose to stay together
you're going to have to rebuild your
marriage from the floor up and I don't
think that's a bad option for you
anyway because I don't know that y'all
were very intentional about how all this
happened she get pregnant and then you
were like it's been four years and
you're like let's just get married and
that's how that
went um no
I it I just
uh it's just one of those things where
like we we're starting to like get our
lives together and stuff and help each
other's passions and everything
and I just felt like you know uh she was
a she was a one I guess yeah yeah okay
but I mean she was carrying your baby
before you got you even proposed
right
um no I I proposed to her before she was
pregnant okay all right let me tell you
something about following your passion
you become really
passionate about what you're good
at and you become really good at what
you practice all the time in the dark
when nobody's
watching and for most of us we either
have some insane internal drive that's
just
crazy or we have a coach or a deadline
that is forcing that upon
us
okay yeah right now you like the idea of
becoming of being paid to be a
writer oh yeah is that fair yeah no it's
been my dreams since in my passion since
I was in second grade all right I want
to give you a stark other side of it
having a book deadline due I turned in a
chapter from my last book on Christmas
Eve I wrote on Christmas day I had a
standoff with my wife in the garage
where she was
sobbing and I had to I was in service to
a book deadline so there's a life to
being an author on the other side and
there's the book tour and then there's
the managing social Med so there's a
whole other side of this thing that is
hard to get passionate about until you
have been grinding it for years okay I
tell you all that's to tell you this you
guys deciding like we're going to
support each other's passions that's not
a good way to approach a
marriage a good way to approach a
marriage is I love you what do you need
from me today to be well and whole and
here's what I
need and then but I've got to get my
passion time time in and get my fortnite
time time in or whatever that's not for
today right you need me to do X Y and Z
I'm in I'm
in and in this world that I've like in
the bookwriting world in the show Making
world the entertainment world it's it's
those who with this
Relentless almost lunatic drive that are
up at before the world is up or is is
still awake late late late at
night because they can't see a world
where they're not they can't breathe
unless they write they can't breathe
unless they create something they can't
breathe I remember a season when I
couldn't get out of my head if I didn't
understand how a psychological theory
worked so I'd stay up all night just
trying to figure it out figure it out
figure it out all my friends said you're
crazy my family said I was crazy it just
became a thing I couldn't turn off but
you're not there yet here's why I'm
telling you all that stuff you and your
wife are GNA have to decide to build
something completely new in October if
you're still together I'm going to give
you and her a pass to the money and
marriage event that me and Rachel Cruz
put on here in Nashville okay okay
tickets aren't even for sale yet it's
it's almost half sold out from people
who went through it last year and
immediately bought um but we're going
I'm going to offer you two tickets and
that's if yall are still together and
October okay all right that's number one
number two I'm GNA give you both of my
books only your past change your future
is about okay the world just hit me now
what yeah that that that would be great
okay and building a non-anxious life the
most the most recent book is a model
it's a path for you and your wife to
build a sustainable
life okay right now you have a baby you
have a marriage that is hanging on by a
piece of of dental floss it's not the
time to follow your passion it's time to
get some economic security you and her
go see a marriage counselor ASAP we
can't afford that I'm telling you right
now you got to have that right um we are
planning on seeing a marriage counselor
this week lots and lots and lots and
lots of people plan on seeing counselors
and they never
go yeah okay if she doesn't show up or
doesn't want to go that's that's that's
what you need to know she's not invested
if you don't show up that's what she
needs to know you're not invested
okay now 30 seconds here's what
preparing for divorce looks
like get to see your kid much less
you're going to have to get a second
place to live or she's going to have to
get a second place to live you're going
to have to navigate child support
separate holidays dating again um
explaining to your friends and family
and figuring out with the kid you see
what I'm saying none of this is easy
yeah no it it definitely does not sound
nor look easy I I witnessed my dad go
through the divorce process and but also
staying with somebody who cheated on you
is not easy
either yeah so you're GNA have to choose
your heart there is no easy path forward
they're both very
difficult
right okay I don't want you to think as
one is easier than the other is what I'm
trying to say they're both gonna be hard
yeah if you still love this woman and
you think you can make it work and she's
willing to rebuild everything with you
that's going to be showing you her phone
or not having phones turning them off
not going out and meeting other people
for lunch and dinner and things like
that they're going to put her in
positions where she can have uh make a
stupid decision on one night that you
are going to plug back in and ask her
every day how can I love you today what
do you need what do you need what do you
need and you show up right if y'all want
to rebuild something that you get some
economic security so y'all are not just
scraping by every second of the
day now I can build something that can
last and continue to sit down with your
old man he's a trustworthy guy sounds
like continue to say hey I'm not doing
okay today or Dad what's your wisdom on
this I love that his first impulse was I
want you to take a breath cuz son I've
been down this road and it was hell and
it caused a lot of problems for me and
my family shake a
breath it's a wise wise man there make
sure to call riy we'll be right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow H is the number one Prayer app in
the world on planet Earth and they're
giving you three free months to get
started and people always say you got to
meditate you got to pray you got to have
a spiritual life and for many of us we
don't even know what that means we don't
even know where to start that's where
hallow steps in three free months to
prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the lowii station that I love
guided prayers meditations and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice mindfulness build a deeper
more meaningful spiritual life to figure
out what you even believe in the first
place and choose peace and remember Hall
is giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90day trial that's hall.com
dealone all right we're back let's go
out to Los Angeles and talk to Jackie
what's up
Jackie hello what up how we doing hi Dr
John my husband and I are huge fan so
thanks so much for having me on thank
you so much I'm a huge fan of you Jackie
apprciate awesome we listen to all of
your shows and you've genuinely become
like a friend to us but we just got to
say we were slightly disappointed when
we found out you were an Astros fan yuck
is that is that is that just simply
because the daughters lose all the
time because because the Astros cheat
all the time so okay cool there's that
there's that well hey since uh y'all
y'all have just gone and purchased
everybody and for a billion bajillion
dollars and I hope you feel good about
yourself you know it's going to be like
I heard a comedian say this once rooting
for the Dodgers moving forward is going
to be like going to Vegas and cheering
for the house like YY go Vegas way to go
way to go Dodgers hope you're happy with
yourself still gonna lose the Astros all
right so what's up G stros well so my
question today is about my
mama okay we'll take a hard left turn
here yep um so for as long as I can
remember I have truly felt that my mom
loves my sister more than me and I feel
so silly calling about this as almost a
30-year-old woman but um uh it it hurts
very badly um it's like a big cut in my
heart that I feel just doesn't heal
because I won't let it in so many ways
but um some of her actions that have
showed this to me include like her
saying like wow like your sister has
such a calling on her life she's so
special she's always been so special and
she says this like like right when we're
both in the same room and she'll be like
oh my gosh like my daughter is just so
beautiful isn't she Jackie and I'm like
hey I'm gorgeous and beautiful too like
um but it's like little things like this
to where like anytime my sister and I
get in a little fight like it's like a
silly little fight or a big fight you
know like sisters do we're four years
apart and we we are the best of friends
though hey we fight um but she always
immediately takes her sides her side no
questions asked no questions asked it
doesn't matter if she came to my house
and you know she doesn't do this by the
way but just hypothetically if she came
over my house and she she
just like completely shattered
everything I owned she would somehow
find a way to take her side um anytime
um she makes weird comments like the
other I'll give you a quick example on
like she made a little comment the other
day on how like my sister's physically
stronger than I am and I'm like hello
I've birthed two children and she's like
yeah know she's physically stronger than
you are and I know that sounds so silly
like something a 15- year-old would get
upset at but whenever I get upset at
these things it's not only that I get
upset I turn into this little
12-year-old girl and I feel like a
10-year-old again I just feel like a
like a little child again and my I just
feel so unloved I guess I don't know um
well my question for you
is um I know that she may never change
oh by the way I may add that whenever I
bring things things up like this she
tells me that I'm crazy and she tells me
that I need to see a therapist because
I'm jealous of my sister and I can
promise you Dr John I'm not jealous of
my sister but I am jealous of my mom and
how she doesn't how special and
beautiful I am and she doesn't respect
my boundaries but she respects my
sisters how do you know how do you know
that well well let me ask you this how
do you know that she doesn't tell your
sister how amazing you are that she's
already given her
grandkids or that that you're so amazing
how do you know that she's not propping
your sister up in front of you because
she sees her sister is so inferior to
the woman you've
become h
can you can you ask that in a different
way again so I can understand that yeah
sure yeah
so
often there's a great saying by Dr Brown
Berne Brown who says what we go looking
for in the world we are sure to
find and so there could
be there could be some objective reality
here okay like my brother brother is a
Kinder man than me he just is he is
disposition he's so
kind and if my mom was to say your
brother's Kinder than you that's a
that's an objective fact he really is
yeah yeah and so if your Mom is saying
she's stronger than you in front of both
of you that could be true that could be
true or like uh any number of things she
makes more money than you she's more
successful than you yeah that I mean if
you look at our tax returns she makes
more money like that could all be true
yeah but what I want to just put in the
in the universe as a
potential is is it possible that when
your mom and your sister are alone your
mom is asking her why don't you have
grandkids yet your sister's given me two
wonderful beautiful
grandkids what about you your sister's
already been married and already has
this and this what about
you M you see what I'm saying yeah
totally absolutely does that happen or
no chance um no okay all right there's
no way yeah I was just trying but maybe
not no no in some ways and I totally get
what you're saying I was actually gonna
add this on my notes I'm like dude I am
I'm like totally okay with my sister
being more beautiful she is she like
physic you know that is a truth that is
a truth in the world and I'm I'm the big
sister I you know I I'm the type of
person I'm like my sister I when I say
she's my best friend I'm like girl I
want you to do better than me in every
area of my life I truly mean that it's
like it's more of
like what do you get from
this what do you mean you are hanging
you hang on to something this
relationship with your mom where she
belittles you treats you like you're
still an elementary school kid that
lives in her home that pits uh you
versus your best friend SLS sister SL um
Confidant you get something from this
interaction otherwise you'd bail what is
it h you know what I CU you wouldn't put
up with a boyfriend treat you like this
no I would not and my husband tells me
that all the time yeah so what what are
you getting from this you know what I I
do enjoy our relationship for the most
part but she just crosses my boundaries
so much she just I feel like she has no
respect for me she clear list Let Me
Clear has none none okay she doesn't and
when you bring it up she says you're
crazy yeah and she says you're the
problem you go fix it yeah what are you
getting from
this nothing just pain in my heart
that's probably not true yeah well no I
mean I love her she I I I enjoy I think
she's one of the most wonderful people
I've ever met and to give you I know
this is no excuse for you I listen to
your show but um her Aces score is an
eight and the only reason it's not a 10
is because she was an orphan and she
didn't have parents to be divorced or be
abusive so she's gone through so much
where
I that doesn't give her that doesn't
give her a pass on how she treats you it
just doesn't yeah and it's not your job
to make sure she's okay for the rest of
her life as and and as her
doormat yeah it's not and that's how you
feel always as a big older child just
like a
doormat I I've always just felt like a
doormat like she just
um um she she'll come into my home and
just immediately criticize I don't know
why I'm I did not plan on crying on the
show it's hard it's hard it's hard it's
okay it's okay so let me ask you what
are you getting from
this I'll tell you what you're getting
you're getting a fantasy that one day
you're going to do the right thing and
finally fix
this and that day is never going to
come and you hang on and you hang on and
you hang
on there's not going to be an amount of
money money that you make there's going
to be a car that you drive up in that
your mom finally goes my God I'm so
proud of you
Jackie it's not going to come is
it
[Applause]
nope that's why you keep showing up you
keep showing up maybe this version is
going to be okay maybe the next version
is going to be okay maybe the next
version of you is going to be
okay and meanwhile you have this husband
at home that loves you so much right so
much he's like honestly awesome just the
best yes and he's like man what why do
you keep going back to this woman he
always tells me that he's like d what
are you doing like yeah listen you're
trying to close a loop and you're not
broken every child on planet Earth does
it everyone does it because we all ask
that question why not
me Mom why don't you love me and your
mom tells you well you're not pretty
enough you're not make this much you
don't have purpose you don't have this
your house my God what are you doing
with your house in your car that's what
you
drive and you think it's about that
checklist that somehow you can solve
that
checklist and you've probably you've
been around long enough half of your
life now from 12 to 12 to 30 let's say
more than half your life every time you
click something off that checklist like
two more boxes end up at the bottom with
the list it just keeps growing you could
never finish
it because it's not about you it's about
your
mom and my guess is she sees herself in
you and when she sees herself in you she
sees that girl that grew up in absolute
hell and her way of trying to make that
Cycle
Stop was to control every second of your
life and and then beautiful fairy
godsister comes along and screws it up
for everybody
right
yeah so here's my big question are you
ever going to sit down across the table
from your mom and say Mom if you do X
and Y and Z again then what you're
asking me is to not come around your
home
anymore are you ever going to do that
and that's not a it's not a setup
question that's not a it's not like a
dare I'm just asking is that is that day
ever going to come uh you know I've done
the I've had these conversations before
and it's like um it worked it was like a
certain situation with the grandkids and
I straight up told her hey if you do
this again and my husband had to step in
he's like hey if you do this again you
can't if you talk to my wife this way
you cannot come into my home and because
it had to do with grandkid she was like
oh immediately I mean it's been she
didn't cross a boundary for years and so
it seems like it's time for that talk
again but it's like she it's like she
almost stopped honoring those B
boundaries but she started um doing it
in a more subtle way now so it's a
little bit harder for me to call out but
I am to answer your question I am
willing to do that talk but I just hate
having those I hate confrontation man I
just oh yeah dude yeah no no kids like
oh I can't wait for this one that's the
worst here's why I ask you this if you
have that in every five years you have
to sit down and have a refresher or
every 5 years your daughters are going
to get a little bit older and a little
bit older and so the things are going to
shift and change a little bit okay mhm
if that's a price to pay for your kids
having a good grandmother and my guess
is she's probably a good grandmother too
which makes this whole thing annoying
right she's like the best grandmother in
the world that's the worst come on yeah
okay so let me let me be real honest and
you know this at some point this turns
on one of your
daughters yeah one of your daughters
becomes the favorite and one of them
doesn't yeah and we're not going to let
this happen
again yeah you've already lived this
this yeah okay it's going to show up in
Christmas presents for one over the
other it's going to show up in dresses
it's going to show up in comments it's
going to show up on all sorts of things
right yeah
okay here's the other side of
it
um you can spend a season
exhaling clinching your fist real tight
and then relaxing it and saying to
yourself she doesn't get a vote h should
get a vote and that sounds so tried at
first but if that becomes something you
practice over time yeah I'm able to be
in the presence of people who have so
many opinions about me and I honestly
don't care I don't
care but I took me a decade to get there
I had to practice
Yeah I had to practice and occasionally
somebody says something to man and I
don't sleep for
days I
don't but it's a practice this MH
because all the other good that comes
with them being in the room is worth
whatever stupid things they going to say
about me or my boss or my friends or my
whatever I don't
care but it took years of me saying you
don't get a vote yeah you don't get a
vote or when she says your sister's so
beautiful you grab your sister by the
face and say I know I'm so lucky to be
her big sister yeah I'm g go right with
it your sister do that it's it's like
roast in the I'm like hey I I do and I
agree but then after I'm like hey like
hearing this every
single day or like every other day you
know I'm like oh it it starts to hurt my
feelings very badly yeah so what we're
not going to do is we're not going to
let Mom hurt her feelings anymore uhhuh
she doesn't have that right anymore
she's lost she's cashed out that right
your husband he still has permission to
hurt your feelings okay he's your right
or die yeah um You probably have one or
two best friends your sister maybe
that's a small crew I think in my little
little box I've got about six mhm six
dudes and one woman who I've given
permission like you can call and cut me
to the
core other than that man you can
frustrate me you can let me have a bad
day you can I mean you can you can push
me into a bad day you can whatever hurt
me
financially but you're not I'm not going
to give you access to hurt my feelings
you don't get that you don't get
that so let me hear let me say this
Jackie you're not
crazy I think you need to I I tell
everybody to do this I feel like but I
think it's really instructive here I
would love for you to write a letter to
12-year-old
Jackie when the whole world figured out
that your younger sister was
beautiful and your mom was trying to
process having two daughters after
growing up in a lifetime of
Hell write a letter to 12-year-old
Jackie and just say hey you're a good
kid and you didn't deserve any of this
stuff write a letter to 22y oldold old
Jackie who met this knuckleheaded
husband of yours who fell in love mom
didn't approve mom kept talking about
how great sister was let her know that
she's
loved and then write a letter to
30-year-old Jackie the woman you're
about to become and by the way you want
to be a gangster read it to your husband
out
loud let him know how important his love
is to you
also but you have to make peace with
12-year-old Jackie and 21-year-old
Jackie and 18-year-old Jackie and
30-year-old jaie Jackie and stop
Outsourcing that pece to Mom cuz you're
not going to get it from
her that call will never
come and that doesn't mean there's not
peace hang on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of own your past change your
future think can be a good book for you
to to work through we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone and I talk about
this all of the time I love love New
Year's resolutions I love the idea of
everyone taking a moment to reflect
consider some ways your life is going
pretty well and some things you'd like
to be different and then actually
setting in place actual steps you can
take to heal and improve your life this
might mean making exercise or great
sleep of priority doing a weekly budget
with your spouse or like I did last year
making therapy an important and
intentional part of your new year and if
you're thinking of starting therapy try
better help because therapy isn't just
for people who've experienced trauma or
who aren't able to function therapy
helps everyone find your strengths
overcome personal challenges and
practice new ways of living and working
to be the best version of yourself
better help is flexible enough to fit
your schedule because it's completely
online just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist plus you can switch
therapists at any time for no extra
charge celebrate the progress you've
already made this year with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com dealone today to
get get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go out to celisa
in Austin Texas what's up
celisa hello how are you party in what
are you up
to n trying to deal with the teen years
good luck with that all the help I can
get yeah good Lu good luck I was about
to call you and ask
you yeah I day by day trying to fig this
out um hoping I value your advice a lot
and so I'm hoping um you can give me
some helpful tips here something we've
kind of been um dealing with for a few
years now um so basically my question in
a nutshell and I can dive in but um my
question is how do my husband and I help
to encourage and support our 16-year-old
son while he's struggling kind of on a
day-to-day basis with a few different
Dynamics um I'll dive into a few of
those um he's recent ly kind of lost his
best friend and group of friends uh he's
struggling a lot to be at school and
being in that
environment he really doesn't have much
of a relationship with his biological
father and so that's been coming up a
lot lately in the last probably two
years and then you know my husband and I
now his stepfather were trying to kind
of create a space where he can process
all of these things that are kind of
going on in his life while
kind of teaching him to have some type
of purpose and not go down these
negative um paths while he's processing
and dealing with all this so that's a
lot to unpack um but curious on any
advice there on on all of this yeah I
got a lot of thoughts here this I mean
this is this is um I have a 14-year-old
and I've have I mean this has been my
career working with um these folks and
so um why did why did his why did he
lose his best friend in his gang what
happened um basically there was some
drama that um happened last year in
school where somebody created a rumor
about my son and his girlfriend and it
really stirred up a lot of drama with
his friend group and they kind of all
didn't want to have anything to do with
it so they took off and really haven't
come back around and his best friend
ended up kind of choosing that side
instead of him okay so it's been tricky
and I think really hurtful for him and
there was um I I
find 14 15 16 17 18 year olds pounce on
rumors and pounce
on um
like Big T like big like William Wallace
statements yeah but when those things
are found to be untrue they Circle back
real fast so is there any truth at all
to
this no
no there was no truth and I think it was
created probably in jealousy um but
nobody's really come back around and I
think my son has really kind of just
internalized and not really decided to
put himself out there again um you know
whether it's making new friends or
talking to other people or reaching back
out I think he really is just I think
he's hurting about it but he's not
really willing to do much about it at
this point and I think we've kind of
pushed him to think about hey there
other you know kids clubs or groups or
church groups or things that you could
maybe be a part of where you have the
opportunity to meet other people um and
this is kind of where I think my husband
and I struggle is what we think is maybe
the helpful solution he's just not ready
for yet and so there's been really no
action on his part
I got one more question for you tell me
about this you're helping him find his
purpose and process this what does that
look like yeah so I think um kind of how
we've been approaching that is one we
have started him in counseling and he's
been on and off with that for a little
bit and we just recently um my husband
and myself and our son have been going
together to kind of work through some of
this and then the other piece of the
processing piece I think is just having
really like open communication with him
and feeling like hey if there's anything
you want to talk about or if there's
books you want to read or any way we can
help you dive into the emotions you're
having we're here but that's kind of
where my question comes in is I don't
want to feel like we're over pushing and
to the point where he kind of uh pulls
more away and so so you know maybe we're
just totally missing some areas that we
could really help him and that's where
we're at I appreciate your care there
and I here's what I want you to know
without a
doubt you are following the The Playbook
perfectly and I think if we were to look
at 18 to 24 year olds 18 to 25 year olds
we have to be honest that the Playbook
doesn't
work because here's what you've done you
have a a son went through something I'm
going to be honest with you I've worked
with young people my whole life with
teenagers and college students high
school kids and college students it's
very rare that someone creates a
myth with no truth to it and every
friend burns them to the
ground sure that's very hard so I don't
know if there's an unwillingness I don't
want to see it or no Mom I promise I
promise and he's just our precious
little baby boy or if this is one of
those rare moments that somebody just
flat made something up about him and his
girlfriend and he lost everything that's
very rare okay uh and that's just me
that's just my experience there but it
could have happened that way here we
are what a 16-year-old is incapable of
doing contrary to what the Playbook
would tell
us is sitting down by themselves and
waiting through their thoughts and
feelings and
emotions and rationally landing on a
series of steps to take
next
they can't do that they're
16 what a 16-year-old has to do is has
to be pushed into they have to do
things yes counseling can be important
for you and your husband and him to
learn how to talk but here's where it
gets in this weird reciprocal cycle it's
it's going to turn into a spiral really
actually already is but it goes into a
spiral real fast here is what it is he
pulls away a little bit and feels a
little bit syrupy I don't want to I'm
not ready yet and what do you and your
husband do you all put something else on
the table well we'll go to counseling
we'll do this thing we'll help you if
you want to do this I'm going to pull
away a little bit more and then we're
going to do and so what he's getting all
what he's getting every little step of
the way is exactly what his body is
craving which is an adult to tell him I
love you and I see you yeah and his dad
cut a hole in his heart by being gone
right yeah yes so what he I'll just walk
through a couple things he desperately
desperately needs number one he needs
you daily touch you're my son I'm going
to hold your face every single day oh
come on Mom come on I'm gonna hold your
face every single day I'm gonna look you
in the eyes and tell you I'm so glad
that God picked me to be your your
mom the second thing is is once a week I
want youall to have some sort of I'm
going to call it a date but you know
what I mean like you take him to
breakfast you you do dinner with just
you two yeah cuz there's that very
strange thing that if he feels himself
gravitating towards his stepfather who
sounds like he's a great guy and good
good man yeah okay that there's that
disloyalty to his biod dad right EXA
that's exactly what he said several
times that he has always felt like he
can't even call him dad because that's
the connection he has really the only
connection he has with his actual dad so
that's right that's right and that's
it's a it's a but often we try to solve
that by forcing new Dad into that
picture you can reinforce it from the
inside out with
you okay you can strengthen that
relationship okay yeah he now the second
thing he's going to need is he has to
have a strong male role
model if not one multiple probably
multiple
right most of the time kids in this
situation some can make the leap to
stepdad they can some can't and that's
where coaches Jiu-Jitsu coaches so
guitar teachers somebody who he actively
is involved with on a regular
basis and so in my house I'll just I'm
tell you what I do in my house my kids
have two options they can do one art and
they have to do one art and they have to
do one
movement that's just a thing and the art
can be an instrument the art can be um
which both of my kids have chosen and
then as my kids one of my kids got older
uh chose theater but they have to do
something expressive where they have to
learn how to create and they have to
learn how to create with a team and
there's a lot of stuff about neural
connectivity and all that kind of stuff
that is like playing instrumental that's
important and yeah they have to do
something with their body does your son
play sports has any involvement anything
movement wise yeah he plays soccer at
his high school and so he's pretty
involved with that and pretty active and
he's got no friends on the soccer
team no and that's kind of the you know
I'll ask him like what about this kid
what about about that and I see you kind
of hanging out with them around soccer
why don't you ask them to go do
something or um you know our son's
driving now so that opens up a little
bit more freedom um and he's just like e
like I've asked him and they just tell
me they're busy and kind of blow me off
so I think he just feels like how much
do I keep pushing if they don't want
with
me yeah I just don't believe him and I
don't I don't I don't not believe him
like as though he's lying but I don't
believe him in like the
um something doesn't ring true
there something's not ringing true sure
they may say no I'm busy cool well what
are we going do next time and here's how
I would handle that if I'm you if I'm
you here's how I would handle that in my
house um my son runs cross country hey
here's the deal son I'm inviting the
cross country team over for dinner I'm
doing that you can pick three or four
people to come over or I'm inviting the
whole team you get to pick now my son
would be like invite everybody that but
that's just kind of how he rolls my
daughter would be a little bit
different but I think we both we you and
I both know the importance of
relationships for for teenagers period
And so I'm not just going to Outsource
that to my 16-year-old and say well you
got to go make some friends you gotta
make some friends no I'm a parent I'm
gonna get involved and it's not an
overly dramatic like I'm over no I'm
going to start having people over to my
house going
to cuz there has to be something there's
something in the water here that's just
not ringing true with me um but he's got
to have movement related things and he's
got to have a relationship with that
coach and if it's not coming through
soccer then maybe he's got to do
something
else and the final thing would be this
um and I think let me say this I think
you're right about group activities I
think you're right about um getting
involved with church groups and things
like that I think all that stuff is good
all that stuff is good give him a chance
to be successful with other friends the
final thing is this I do think your
stepfather plays a
role and if it's a matter of saying dad
or calling him Steve or Dan or whatever
that's not a battle that's not a hill I
would die on at this point but we're
looking for is um we want a picture of
what that looks like of what a male
relationship with your 16-year-old son
looks like and so that might mean that
your husband begins to take him out to
breakfast and it starts on breakfast one
is I know you feel like you're betraying
your dad and so I'm not trying to get in
the middle of
that that's your dad and that's for yall
twoo to work out
together but we live in the same house
together so we're going to be friends
and I'm going to get involved that way
and there's going to be a constant
here's the key a NeverEnding show up I'm
going to show up I'm going to show up
I'm going to show up and he's going to
show up your husband's going to show up
he's going to show up and your son is
going to do what he can over time to
push him away and it's not going to work
because I love you
kid and what your son is going to learn
in real time oh this is what being a man
actually looks like because my dad
abandoned me and until he can metabolize
that it's going to be tough a tough road
to Ho for him but your husband's going
to show him this is what men do they
keep showing up for their sons they keep
showing up they keep showing up they
treat their their mom like this they pay
their bills like this they do a budget
like this and so maybe it's just life
lessons hey I'm going to teach you how
budgets work I'm going to teach you how
how a household runs I'm going to teach
you how to fix a car I'm going to teach
you some things but we got to have those
relationships and it might be hey I'm
gonna start taking Jiu-Jitsu after
soccer season's over I want you to take
it with me um we're gonna do it together
um and you can call me Steve call me
Steve all the way through if you're
never comfortable calling me dad that's
fine I'm not going to force that um and
I think it's good for him to keep seeing
a counselor about his dad because his
dad left him and that's going to leave a
a dad sized hole in that heart for a
long long time
what we're looking for now that he's 16
we're looking for him when he's 22
24 and he's able to feel inside his
nervous system but also look back in
memory and say oh no no I got a picture
of a man who kept showing up it is my
stepdad I got a picture of a mom who
never ever let me
pass she grabbed my face every single
day and said I love
you my parents made made me have friends
it was so awkward and so weird and they
made me I'm so glad they
did but right now we have a lot of
talking and a lot of how do you feel and
a lot of processing let's begin to move
towards action the processing is still
important having that conversation is
still good I recommend putting a spiral
notebook on his bed and you you and him
can go back and forth or the three of
you can go back and forth and writing
things down that tends to be a little
bit more of a uh an honest way to
communicate with a teenager sometimes
because everything sucks or it's the
worst or I'm fun um sometimes writing it
down is very
helpful um letting them see that you're
grateful for them letting them see that
it was a really hard day together but I
love you and I'm confident tomorrow's
going to be a better day letting him see
that and read it and then have to write
back to you today was fine today was
okay I really wish that fill in the
blank whatever that is but that may be a
good way to yall communicate together
and continue to process the stuff
together but let's move towards
action let's move towards movement let's
move towards action let's move towards
relationship not just thinking about
thinking about it and feeling about it
I'm send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life I want you to check
that book out as a family and maybe
that'll give you all a road map towards
kind of what I'm talking about here
we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we're back and everyone's
favorite EP uh whatever segment is that
what we call it not episode segment
segment I think it's good am I the
problem all right or is it me this is
from Tim in Goan or goshan I'm not real
sure Kentucky hooked on fonic okay how
do you pronounce it I don't know World
Geography mellan over there I don't know
I just made that up go okay anyway all
right am I the problem I'm 16 years old
and at my work my boss was dis excuse me
my boss was disrespectful to a customer
over a minor issue they had an argument
about my manager's attitude and
dismissiveness later my boss vinced me
about the argument complaining that the
customer as always uh let's see as if he
was complaining about the customer as if
he had done something wrong she asked me
if I was in the right and I said that
the way she came off at the start of the
conversation may have been received as
rude now every time I go to work she
acts offended and speaks to me as little
as possible should I have just not said
anything no 16-year-old I'm proud of you
I know this is a great kid that's a kid
that was raised right and that has got
good character and is strong good for
good for you 16-year-old Tim yeah 100%
believe that this is a good kid his
parents should be very very proud they
should and Tim go find another job life
is too short to work for bosses that
have no character and no integrity and
they're going to take out their their
hurt feelings on a 16-year-old who's got
more character in his two in his two
feet than this your yes you are right
Tim good for you it makes me happy yeah
it's hope for the future and Tim even
said it right he wasn't like yeah you
were totally rude he's like well you
could have come off is rude I know the
way he handled it was pretty impressive
he's like a married man like he knows
how to take the edge off a little bit
good for him yeah so no good for you Tim
you're making me believe in the future I
believe the children it's a rough
sleding out there
Kelly future doesn't look great
sometimes but lucky for us we're
entering into an election season which
everyone's super thrilled
about oh jeez so with that joyful News
America choose to treat your neighbors
kind turn off the
news just go be a positive addition to
your community cuz I think that's what
we got right now love you guys see you
[Music]
soon